If the topic of politics hasn’t been terrifying
enough for you over the past several years,
let us introduce to you SCP-1981: The even
more frightening version of ex-president Ronald
Reagan.
Well, technically it’s an old VHS tape of
Ronald Reagan giving a speech, which doesn’t
take long to become traumatic and disturbing.
As the speech goes on, Reagan seems to fall
apart and zombify, often being mutilated in
various disgusting ways that vary from play
to play.
His speech also devolves into violent, frightening
nonsense, as well as sometimes differing from
a typical Reagan speech.
Most frightening of all is that sometimes
a figure in a black cloak will appear on screen.
To this day, nobody knows exactly who this
figure is, or what the true origin or purpose
of the tape is.
And according to some reports, being subjected
to the tape and then being given a botched
amnestic treatment afterwards was a major
contributing factor in the death of the real-life
Ronald Reagan.
Conspiracy much?
Maybe.
Maybe not.